hey everybody is Jessie and today we're
gonna switch over to using the newest
version of material UI so this will be
let's see we started with the the stable
version then we switched to the alpha
then we switched back to what we
originally had and then a few days ago
the beta version came out so now we're
switching to that so I know we talked
about switching yesterday and I didn't
realize when we were talking about it
that the beta version had already come
out so I saw that on Twitter afterwards
and I felt really stupid and then a few
of you messaged me and told me about it
so thanks for giving me the heads up on
that I appreciate that let's see alright
somebody in the in the live chats asking
how do I get started with a series this
is only the fourth stream in the series
for this particular project so just go
back to where it says I think starting
my new react project if you want to see
like the very beginning of the series
you actually have to go to to my channel
my personal channel the links in the
description and if you if you check I
can't remember what the name is I think
it's the the first video is like
building a website as fast as I can that
might be the title so I did a few videos
on my own channel before I got invited
to livestream for this channel so that's
where project one started but project
two we're still in the beginning phases
of that
all right yeah and I am at work today so
the video quality should be good
sorry again about yesterday's quality
I'm I'm in the middle of actually
switching over so I'll show you how it's
going so this is how it's going so far
it's not too bad they were more there
were more errors so I've gotten it down
I've just been slowly working through
error messages because it's definitely
different
so this switch once I switch it's not
going to be that easy to go back so
there's differences I guess this will be
really good for anyone to watch if
you're thinking about switching so let
me go through some of the differences
that I've noticed so far and I had to
change let me bring up the code so I
think this this is a good one where I
had some differences all right so
originally we were bringing in app bar
and actually if you check out the code
that's in the git repo right now it's
the old code I haven't pushed any of the
new stuff up yet because there's errors
on I never really liked to push errors
unless something comes up and I have to
leave work and I just I need to push it
so as soon as I get rid of the errors
I'll push up the new code but for now
it'll be alright because you can check
on github what we did have and how we
had to change it so I did leave some of
the code in here seek at least see some
of what we had down here and we did
change some stuff up here but you have
to check that out and github so they
make this a bit bigger
we had app bar we're bringing in app bar
from material UI and all we had to do
was put in a title and that's what
show up at the top of our our app and
you know then we had some other options
for like clicking clicking the menu
button and that was it it was pretty
simple we've replaced this with this
button app bar and this is a component
that I've made but I basically just
copied and pasted everything from the
docks for the latest version of material
UI so let me show you what I do so in
order to get that same thing with I'm
still not even sure this will work since
I keep getting so many errors but in
order to get that same thing it's a lot
more complicated so I'm not necessarily
saying that's a bad thing it seems like
they'll be it'll be easier to customize
things like this so I think it will end
up being a good thing but for now it's
just I'm gonna definitely have to change
you know how we were doing things but
basically we've got now instead of just
a bar we have app bar toolbar typography
button icon button menu icon so we're
putting all of that together here and
you can see some of the stuff is still
similar I guess we have this is a little
bit odd you know instead of being able
to put the title we actually have to put
it inside typography so I haven't played
with it enough to know whether or not
you absolutely have to have this but for
now I'm just gonna kind of leave it
there once I get it working then we can
try to customize it and see what you
know what happens there's a little bit
so I've noticed for some things I've had
to switch to this type of import so
before for some of the things I could
just import it like this like I'm doing
with what say you know app bar toolbar
so import app bar from material UI and
slash app bar I was getting errors on
some of that
those and I had to switch it to look
like this import and then inside my my
curly brackets I'd have to put it listed
so I just kind of keep going back and
forth to the documentation and trying to
figure out what the new way of doing it
is so that's what I've been working on
so far I had to change okay this is a
good example so before I was able to
bring in menu item just like this so I
would so I would import menu item from
material icons or material uimenuitem
now I had to switch it and I have to
import menu item from material you I'm
menu so there's just little things like
that that aren't really a big deal but
it's a big enough deal to give you an
error message so I'm sure it'd only take
a few days to get used to how everything
is especially since I wasn't really that
used to the old way so right now I mean
I'm just gonna work try to work through
these error messages and let me bring
pull that over there and bring this over
so our error message that we're getting
now and make this bigger Oh actually
before we get into anything I do want to
say thank you to Patrick and Sebastian
for their pool requests so actually a
lot of the stuff I just showed you
probably seemed weird because those are
all new things from pool requests so I'm
sorry I totally forgot so a lot changed
since yesterday let me take you through
some of the changes just so that we're
all on the same page so most of the
changes are available in github right
now so you can check them out as I'm
going over them but right now in terms
of how everything looks it all looked
pretty much the same the changes were
just how everything's laid out behind
the scenes the only difference that you
could see was Sebastian had
the different background color to that
active class so that it actually did
show there was a visual representation
of what page you were on when you open
that that side drawer so this is what so
this side nav component this was all
Sebastian so he created the side nav
component now of course as I said I've
edited it to work with the newer
material UI but the bulk of it is still
the same
I also edited the side nav to add this
the sidebar item component so this is a
component now so what I had done is so
Patrick had submitted a pull request and
it was the second pull request then
Sebastian submitted pull request three
so I think they were both working at the
same time so Patrick had worked on some
of the same stuff that Sebastian was so
I kind of combined the two so I merged
and Patrick to pull requests and I
turned what he had you know he had
basically had this component inside the
main app.js file so it was just like
okay I mean obviously I don't have it in
here but it was just above here you know
as a functional component and then he
could you know call it you know down
here this is all now changed a lot as
well but basically I just took that I
made it a component so that allowed me
to use it this sidebar item inside the
nav could side nav component that
Sebastian had made so it worked out
pretty well I had some trouble getting
everything working but that was just
entirely due to me messing up the prop
names so for a second I thought I had
some like really weird bug but it
was just just using the wrong prop name
so that happens let's see anything else
okay on app dodge is a lot did change
here as well so you Sebastian change it
to use this switch so it's it's a lot
more concise and you can see our app
component now it's way shorter than it
was so the top part where we're
importing things actually you know we do
have a lot of different things imported
now Sebastian took all those can all
those views and he imported them all so
now they're actually working so you can
see each one has like the bare-bones it
needs to be a component which is awesome
and so now this is all imported and so
you can see what our routes will render
each one of these views depending on
what the URL is Sebastian also added a
component in case it's it's some URL
that's not here it's just just like a
catch-all to tell users like hey that
URL doesn't have anything so I think
that's also Sebastian Sebastian did a
lot of stuff in his pool request he
added in the theme properly which I had
to take a lot out of things so here's
the theme right now because I was
getting weird errors with the colors and
I realized that I don't actually need to
import the colors cuz I was just using
the default colors anyway and the only
color I had change was primary so I got
rid of everything that didn't matter
except this primary color that had
changed and we can just add back in what
we need as we go based on the new
documentation and then that'll that'll
help us get up and running a little bit
faster right now because you know just
one less there
you less areas that we have to worry
about but anyway thank you so much
Patrick and Sebastian that helped a lot
and made things a lot more clean and it
took care of a lot of stuff some of
which I had no idea how to do so it
would have taken me a long time to
figure it out so okay now that we're all
caught up and everyone should have a
decent idea of where we're at today
we're gonna start fixing these errors so
we're going to look at cannot Reaper you
at bar of undefined in at barge s54 so
that's not I don't like this error
because at bar isn't even our component
right at bar is at bar comes with with
the theme so we're gonna have to look at
the documentation then and see what the
heck's going on with a bar so we have a
bar it's just an aesthetic bringing a
bar see that this is actually really
weird because I copied and pasted this
exactly from the documentation and that
should be the only place that we're
actually using a bar let's double check
and make sure we didn't leave it in
anywhere so inside I mean other than
here which I can get rid of this now
other than their I don't think we're
using a bar anywhere let me check the
live chat quickly I haven't even said hi
to everybody yet
also this is being broadcast
simultaneously on YouTube and on
Instagram so if you're watching on
Instagram check out the free code camp
YouTube channel and you can see the code
that I'm working on and if you're
watching on YouTube if you would like to
see my face and some of my office while
I'm doing this you can check me out on
Instagram and the link to that is in the
description for this video all right so
let's see hey everybody
Sharan is asking about links to my
channel in the description okay it looks
like you found it so awesome Joel says
hi from Bolivia hey how's it going
thanks for watching
all right so getting some comments about
I guess the new material you I wrote on
says looked at Mervyn's here UI and I
actually like how it bundle those
multiple exports into one where it makes
sense but the thing is you wouldn't
immediately know without referring to
the docs mm-hmm alright cool yes and the
the editor is Adam to tell you the truth
I'm pretty sure we had a few streams
where no one asked about the code editor
I was kind of disappointed maybe I'm
mistaken maybe I have to go back and
watch the streams but I'm pretty sure no
one asks maybe yesterday or last week at
some point I know there was at least one
where I don't think anyone asked so
broke the streak
and then says hi campers any good
resource to learn jQuery real quick
I think the free code camp course goes
through jQuery at first write the jQuery
documentation is actually really easy to
read so I would check that out
as far as documentation goes some
documentation is super difficult to read
and but I think the jQuery Doc's are
really really easy so I had some similar
just joined an Instagram hey how's it
going a couple people join in thanks for
watching if you want to see the code
check it out on free code camp youtube
tone asks a fellow include redux I don't
think I'm going to include Redux in this
project I don't think it'll be needed
but I'm there are plans for doing a
really really big website in react and
if that's the case I'm probably going to
use some more advanced things for that
so that projects coming so if just a
little sneak peek the main website for
the university needs redone it's like
three years old at this point and the
system it's built on is going extinct so
we need to redo it and I'm like 90% sure
it's gonna be redone with react and
there's gonna be cool stuff with load
balancing so we're gonna have lots of
lots of servers with load balancing
going on and lots of caching and things
so because it needs to handle a lot of
traffic so that's going to be fun to do
so all these little react projects are
building up to that I'm purposely
testing out different things don't eat
on that project so that's my plan so
that's coming
okay Umberto says hey Jessie are you
able to comment out the place where you
use app bar and see if the error goes
away then debug from there I guess I
could but really like I'm using app bar
here you know and it's wrapping its
wrapped there on all this stuff so I'm
not sure I can't just comment that out
without commenting all this stuff out
and then that's basically the whole
component what I could I guess like
where am I using this set button hat bar
I guess I could comment this out really
quick and then I have to comment this
out too so don't get in err
so if you're new to react and you can't
figure out how to do comments inside JSX
this is how you do it it took me forever
to figure this out I used to get errors
because I tried to do comments and they
wouldn't work so you have to use the
curly brackets to drop into JavaScript
and then you put your multi-line
comments and that's how you have to
comment it out it's a little bit more
work alright so I'm gonna do that and
just see what I get I don't even know
where my there we go okay so I actually
did get a different error let me show
you what I've got going on over here
so this is the the app so nav drawer is
now undefined
yeah and that's actually in this is
another area that's that's within this
material UI drawer component
so I don't know what is going on
let me read a few more comments here to
see if anyone has any ideas for me hey
Jordan Jordan says hi hey Jordan Phillip
said Patrick saving Jesse's job one pull
request at a time I like that I mean I'm
pretty sure I still have a job but I
really do appreciate all the pull
request it does make me look better that
I have these I give you all credit
though even like in meetings all uh when
we have our our department meetings I do
bring up you know that you all have
submitted pull requests most of the
people in the meeting have no idea what
I'm talking about
I try to explain it but sometimes it's
better just to say I've lots of people
helping me
XANA says she doesn't have Instagram oh
uh I didn't have an Instagram until
maybe two months ago and it's kind of
fun I never thought it would it would
really be I didn't think I'd be into it
but it is kind of fun
all right Sebastian says remove the
prototype Moop remove the prop types oh
okay
is that what's causing my errors then
actually
oh really Oh unsaid my Instagram
livestream keeps on buffering so I don't
really know I I'm really new with
everything on Instagram so I'm not I'm
not even sure if I can change settings
or anything it seems really basic you
just hit a button to go live and there's
not really any options
alright so here's what I do want to say
this is it possible is it possible that
some stuff from the old version could
have been left behind
I do remember reading in the in the
changelog something about I thought it
was something about z-index being
removed and that is actually part of
what era I was getting
all right bill says maybe delete yet
then it sounds like a good idea I'm
gonna go and I'm gonna delete material
UI and then I'm gonna reinstall it and
after I delete material UI I will
manually check to make sure that it
really is deleted so let's go and I mean
this is where the shot this is really
easy and if it fixes it that'll save a
lot of time okay now let's check our
node modules so we should have alright
so there's no material UI we have the
icons there but I'm gonna leave them
because I've had no issues with the
icons alright now I will
I did the at next version and that did
give me the the latest beta version is
there some other way to do this that
would get I mean I assume at this point
it'll be fine it'll just give me the
latest version so I did double-check in
the node module to see what the version
number was and I think it's beta v1 and
it's like 0 0.2 or something like that
Johnny asked if I'm using Ubuntu no not
for my machine it's it's Mac I usually
blew through all my servers 16 point o4
yes uh ones using the Bluetooth so as
Anna
I'll join you said the console looks
like Linux this is actually I term 2 for
the console I mean it's all the same
commands that you would use in Linux
alright well hopefully that make a
difference I'm gonna restart the server
as well since that seems to help
sometimes
and I really wanted to start use using
and rock like I had mentioned yesterday
but is if I'm just getting errors right
now there's really no point oh I'll
start it if we get these fixed sorry if
you're watching on Instagram I my phone
just fell over and you're looking at the
ceiling so I just noticed that hopefully
it wasn't going on for a while let's see
all right Sebastian says make sure you
updated all the old version components
to the beta ones
all right let's see natural
I'm gonna check out I guess is really
not not much I can do except try to
check out the docs for everything that
I'm getting an error for and where I
lost my dog oh hey there alright so I'll
bring ease over and I'll leave this air
up and so let's check out drawer
okay it looks like there is some
different stuff for the drawer sorry
that was really small I didn't didn't
realize that okay I'm gonna move this
over to my other screen so I can compare
it with the code that we're currently
using for the drawer just to see if
we're we're doing this the right way so
I'm looking at the documentation for the
newest version of material UI so I had
you have to click the bar if you're
gonna go to material - you i.com you
have to click the bar at the top that
says all ya material UI v1 is coming I
like that that's fun so I'm just gonna
check to see that I am importing what I
need to import
and see
all right they definitely they have a
different way of doing this this handle
close I doubt that would be messing us
up
it's probably worth a shot
and now it's saying like instead of
saying this state let me bring this over
so there's a lot more options going on
here so you can open it from all these
different places so this state open left
then they have different ways to close
it so maybe I ought to pull in a lot
more what's going on here
let me get check back in the live chat
Rowen says at this point I would just
try modifying other modules by hand and
commenting out the offending lines
yep sometimes I do things that make
people kill themselves
one says wouldn't it help to look for
more info in the Aires call stack that's
close yeah embarrass it says just
remember to uncomment your button a part
yeah maybe I should just uncomment that
for now and then take these one at a
time so we'll come back to the drawer
thing let's handle this we'll handle
them in order I have a feeling that once
we figure out one or two of these then
the rest won't be as big of a deal
oops I forgot to uncomment this there we
go okay now let's see what our air was
and this one was giving us the air here
okay so it is this z-index thing again
so for both of the components the air
we're getting has to do with this
z-index themes the index at bar
hmm
actually let's check out let's check
this out
hmm
I'm looking looking for things that were
really new
now as to
all right it's worth the shot to just
throw this in the Google search and see
hello so I didn't really have much hope
since this version just came out so let
me go back to
I wonder we so I did have something I
mentioned earlier that I took a lot of
stuff out of my theme and I did have
some stuff in there I think about the
index maybe it was about shadows I hope
that that wasn't somehow required and
now my themes overriding stuff and it
has no there's nothing in there
all right let's check out our theme
hmm
I have
yeah let's check what it says about
themes then says that seems to be the
issue
here we go
seems he annexed a poor okay so in here
in this thing we do have z-index at bar
let's check out what we actually have
and some triage styles theme jazz
alright let's check out our theme JS
file
all right this looks different let's
looks like we have
the index touches
okay it looks like it's here so so this
should be getting imported into the
themes well let's just copy this it's
copy all of this and let's put it in our
custom theme so let's see should be
z-index
all right not sure if that'll do
anything
heeey
they see where my terminal went I moved
it over
all right cool hey we fix that error ha
ha
so hey guess what I have a better idea
what if let's just copy everything in
this theme Jas since it seems like it's
legit and we'll paste it into the theme
guess and our node module or better yet
let's just paste it into our custom
theme so we don't have to mess with our
node modules so I mean a little bit
repetitive here to have it all in there
but instead of going through one by one
it's think I think it makes a lot more
sense to do it like this let me make
sure where this starts okay
all right
stange it still Evers all right what is
it now
color theme get palette did did my
restarting of the server actually do
anything maybe it did
okay all right so let's let's look
specifically at what's going on here
no that's not what we're a par 74 color
theme palette you're conscious
okay
alright let me go back to the to the lab
chat for a minute here
let's see
all right
yeah so I'm not good thing everybody was
still talking about z-index and I'm not
I'm pretty sure that we've we've kind of
with I don't want to say we fix the
problem because really we just like
worked around it but contrast Texas not
hmm
so the problem with everything is this
theme file where's mine
so this is really small let me make it
bigger okay
it really wasn't even a theme is there
yeah
sebastien s is that the old version
theme now I think this these are the
dogs now you're right it did switch over
I thought I had the it must have
switched over when I went to issues so
good call on that Sebastian okay now we
can actually see this
okay palate
this good Hallet
there we go
so I suppose whatever is they're saying
it's not a function should be in this
palette file all right which one were
you looking for get contrast text yep
this is it all right so for some reason
it can't find that
Why Why cannot find that let's see if we
have a pallet J s file in our high
modulus under Styles polishes
get contrast text okay so we have it all
right so we we obviously have the right
function here
okay it is bringing in pallet
okay so I don't maybe I'm missing
something I'm gonna go to a live chat
and see but it seems to me like we just
saw that this theme Dodge is is pulling
in pilots which is requiring pallet and
then when we looked in pallet we did
have the correct function all right so
let me scroll up a bit
Frances asks can we fork your project
and fix it for you yeah you can I don't
really want to push things with errors
up to github but I I might I might push
this actually it won't let me my commit
hook will probably not let me push this
up
all right let's see
huh Joe honey says the next video should
be named problem-solving with Jesse yeah
honestly sometimes that's that's what
happens so hey with someone else joined
us in on the Instagram livestream so
welcome if you want to check out the
code that I'm working on go to free code
camps YouTube channel and then you get
to see what I'm seeing on my screen
alright John Hanson said the Instagram
live feed is great as it's not delayed
sound to the YouTube live video cool
alright that's cool
I mean I'll I never realized that it was
pretty cool
Patrick says you're using the old theme
way with the new beta way check out the
docs for themes okay cool I will do that
so let me see I think I have the docs up
here still I thought I did did I move
him yeah yeah I did I moved him to the
other screen so I could see better so
let's do the provider
so it's full and so here's where I'm
here's my FPS thing obviously I copied
over pretty much everything let's see
all right so maybe I am I'm thinking so
I did update and where we get an app j/s
I updated to thought I updated to the
new way of pulling in a theme so we
changed before this was different
and so I updated that and also how we
pull in the theme as well
all right so maybe I'll pull this over
so y'all can see what I'm looking at
here so this is under the new
documentation at the bottom of the
themes page so maybe creating the theme
is different as well
so
maybe I need to do something like this
alright so let's try
gets us to change the URL too
oops
put down the wrong spot with the
Fierstein
does that look right that does not look
right let me see
okay definitely get an air
maybe I'm looking at the wrong
John Henson in the live chat says great
news I installed react on top of web
hack pain in the works now using router
as well for multiple pages links not
trying to see if I can get sass to build
separate files for each page that's
awesome definitely let me know how sass
works out for you
synthetic today how did I put that in
the wrong place probably I did
yeah
I'm still getting that air yeah John
said the Instagram feed did die yeah so
I guess Instagram has a limit of an hour
on live streams so only the first hour
of anything I do gets good streams
imagine my stream was probably super
boring for Instagram because it was a
lot of me just looking at a screen I
wasn't doing much talking so alright so
I'm not sure
I'm not exactly sure where to get an X
from here no you think for a minute uh
uh so I mean we had we made some
progress and then we're stops
okay let's see if we have a pallet
what was where is our our github
documentation for pallet
I can't do this can i this isn't gonna
work
is there any way for me to put a
function inside this object this I feel
like this is like just objects 101 but
we have figured I can't do that what if
I get contrast ratio I hope I do like
this
okay
okay so faster exists JavaScript has
first-class functions of course you can
put a function and an object or not like
that just because you can doesn't mean
the material UI knows how to use it yeah
at this point I was just continuing on
with our process of putting everything
that we get an arrow and into our into
our theme but it looks like this pulls a
lot of other stuff so it's probably not
a great idea because well we will
literally end up having to put
everything into there when the problems
seems to be for some reason
things aren't getting pulled into themed
ijs properly
actually hold on this this looks weird
maybe I'm missing something I might be
missing something one on in here but
look in here it's saying palette is
palette right but up here we're naming
it underscore palette where else are we
are we getting are we changing that
somewhere okay here we go
looks like we're defining palette here
Rohan says I think it's the wrong way to
go having to put everything in a custom
theme file yeah I agree I think it was
worth a shot if I could just get it to
work with just the part that I put in
but if I have to put in more than it's
not it's going to be too much
Tylar s in the lodge at what's your
opinion on these new nano degree
programs popping up and I'm going to
answer that just to take a little break
from this I'm I'm doing the react
nanodegree program from Udacity right
now in terms of the course quality and
content I'm impressed with it so far
I don't know firsthand whether a nano
degree is helpful or getting a job
excuse me he's yawning
today is day two with no caffeine I
think I'm gonna take a little break from
it and see if it helps me sleep but I am
you own anymore
so anyway I don't know personally
whether it helps getting a job of course
you like I've read online that you know
companies are starting to recognize them
but I don't really know you know how
many companies and so I'm not I'm not
really sure if your main goal when
taking a nano degree is to learn and you
want to get feedback to do like the paid
version and you know get a you know
actually end up with a nano degree then
I think it's good for that I just I kind
of wonder like what people think when
they see nano degree on a resume does
that really mean anything or not I think
at some point it might mean something
into some companies it might mean
something but I'm just not sure yet but
I think it's you definitely learn a lot
all right okay Patrick I see your your
comment here you can't
are you using create Mui theme which is
how the dogs did let's see
yeah so here's what I'm going up here
Rowen says are we importing Mui theme
provider yes I am importing that as well
yeah that's the thing some stuff was
working and even before I changed all
this around which I couldn't even keep
track of what I was doing I think I I
think I've messed this up I should
probably just undo everything since it
was working but this was you know it
fixed that z-index issue that we were
having so obviously this was getting
used somehow but I actually do think I
should just undo all of the stuff I did
in here I don't know they did it is
fixing the z-index issue still right let
me let me take out this stuff I did down
here
we got accidentally set a debug point
didn't realize it okay yeah so that that
that actually is taking care of that
z-index issue it's going farther down in
at bar Jaso the z-index thing was up
here in line 54 now we've we've made it
all the way down the line 74 and now is
this pilot thing
let me see I see I'm barrister I see
what you're saying shouldn't that be
from interior UI styles and UI theme
provider let me see where I was having
that I think I pulled this I think I
pulled this right from the docks let me
double-check
yeah Patrick said I feel like this beta
is an alpha yeah kind of regretting
regretting the decision to do this the
good thing is let me check my git log
and see what I've actually done I don't
know that I've actually committed any of
this so we could just go back easily
yeah so if this endeavor fails it won't
be hard to go back to where we were at
that's that's the beauty of get in
version control in general so if you
aren't using it this is a great reason
to use git is if you if you mess up your
app just pretty much beyond repair which
is it's kind of what I think I've done
just now
then then it can help you can just go
back mmm same thing
oh actually we've got okay so I had gone
in here and mess with some stuff
actually okay so this makes at least
this will help us narrow down so it's
it's able successfully at least it was
able to go into a theme palette
background at bar but then when it tried
to theme palette get contrast text it
couldn't work so it it actually is
importing so the issue then would
probably be within palette dot Jas
okay so this is where it is actually
returning get contrast text
and that is yeah that is the name of the
function
okay I said now I'm seeing what you all
were saying about pushing into another
granite branch first okay let's see
so is that is there like a shortcut way
for me to switch to another branch and
commit these or do I need to commit them
to master and then push to another
branch and then just roll back the
commits
okay david says there is a shortcut way
if anybody commits directly to branch
alright let me check so like commit
directly to to the UH to another branch
okay cool it comes up as one of the
options in the Google search
all right making new parents check it
out and the change will come with you
and you changed and I had the chance to
see wrench commit
okay I had no idea that you could do
this
alright let me pull over I'm gonna do
this so everybody can see it
okay so this everybody knows what I'm
doing I am on the master branch and I
don't want to commit these changes to
master branch
I've decided according to the advice of
you all that I should commit these on a
different branch and then push it up to
github and then that way everyone can
see what's going on so that's what I'm
attempting to do so I'm gonna get
checkout Hey and then we're gonna say
material you are beta
okay cool
awesome everything's right here grades
I can't believe that made it through I
thought for sure I had done something
that was gonna cause an error that's
awesome alright oops
cool all right now it's on github cuo
can see the mess that I've made
yeah that's why I get
all right
okay so this should be working because
it's undone everything but for some
reason it's not
there we go sir I didn't I didn't
install the right packages so that's
that was the problem
all right so at least now I can show you
show you this the the highlighting of
the page you are on is working so I
think this is what's yeah
I think what I'll do for now maybe is
give up on the idea of using the newest
version so the whole point of me wanting
to use the beta version instead of the
normal one is for the coulomb class
components and I figured that that would
save me time in the long run by having
all those extra components and it would
be worth the set-up time and
transferring it over I think now that
that does that's not true anymore so the
time I thought it would take to get this
working was way less than what it's
actually taking and then that's no
longer a good decision time was I think
it would be faster for me to just make
my own column classes and use them I
mean I could potentially even try to
model them after what's in the beta if I
want to but that's just too much also
I'm a little worried that if I run into
errors since it's so new there's not
going to be a whole lot of other people
talking about those errors all right one
has to go see later one thanks for for
joining us what Sun isn't that okay it's
about 3:30 so yeah I think now's a good
time for me to admit defeat for today
and wrap things up so all in all today
did did get a lot of stuff done behind
the scenes in terms of getting the pull
requests in and making some extra
components and things so it wasn't you
know in terms of trying to do the switch
to the beta that that definitely was a
failure but did I did get some stuff
done on
the site and can always come back since
we've you know save those changes in
another branch it's entirely possible to
come back to that at some point but for
right now I'm not sure that's the best
idea so this is gonna be a very good
lesson to me and maybe to someone else
out there that it's probably better just
to pick something and stick with it and
not try to keep changing it because I've
definitely wasted a lot of time I don't
want to say wasted I mean learned some
stuff along the way but it could have
been using that time to actually build
this out so don't like to I don't ever
really like to back down from trying to
figure something out but at some point
there's just not enough time to figure
some things out
bill wrote react project to day ten
design decided for real this time that
actually does sound like something I
would type if you've ever seen my commit
messages if I try to commit something
and I accidentally don't commit what I
wanted to my next commit message is
always do this thing for real this time
so it is how I would say it okay so I'm
gonna go back through the chat now and
see if there's any questions that I
missed I'm sure there probably is
because I was so focused on this so if
you have any questions put them in the
live chat now if you can't stick around
for the chat it Patricks if you can't
stick around for the chat just direct
message me on twitter or put it in the
comments to this video and I'll get to
him whenever I get a chance
Patrick said dude commit amend yeah I
actually did do an amend on a project I
was working on my lunch break so I have
done that before but usually honestly
usually I don't even care enough to do
an amend because it's just me working on
these projects so um although now you
all are working on them with me but like
in the past it's always been just me
working on these projects and no one
ever looked at my gig commits so I got
was lazy about it and I said I'll just
do another commit it would be faster so
I probably should start using amend more
but
all right so let me go through the chat
here and if you got to leave now thank
you so much for watching I'll be back
tomorrow all right
looking through right actually not
really a lot of questions so far in the
chat oh I see you all have made some
comments on JSX
comment tags being ugly I agree I mean
it's not really that big of a deal I
guess but I do wish there were a simpler
way in a nicer looking way to do
comments
so Jan asks can you recommend me a good
tool for debugging j/s that was that's a
long time ago so I'm not sure if you're
still around but I mean dev dev tools is
pretty good chrome dev tools is good
does anyone know of anything better than
then chrome dev tools that's easy to use
I mean I assume you're talking I guess
about you know regular JavaScript I'm
not sure how good dev tools is a
debugging like node or I don't know if
you're trying to do something with react
native or something like that
I'm sure maybe there's different
debuggers for that but if just talk
about like normal JavaScript that most
people write
I think dev tools is pretty good I
haven't really used much of anything
else though so maybe there's other
things out there and not aware of
nam says hi everyone I'm a new person
I've gotten into programmer I like
working on back-end or to be software
engineer in general someone here could
you suggest the programming language you
like most I think this is not going to
be a surprise to anyone I'm gonna say
JavaScript so yeah it did
I guess if your question is simply what
do you like the most then I would say
JavaScript although I did enjoy Python
when I did some stuff in Python just
because of like all the indentation and
stuff it was really easy to do and you
could actually program with Python on a
phone it was easy with the phone
keyboard normally programming on a phone
keyboard is ridiculous because you know
all the brackets and everything that you
need take forever to get to someone
should make an app that's a phone
keyboard for programmers and you could
have custom keyboards depending on the
language that you're using that would be
awesome I would like that app I mean I
don't really plan on programming that
much on my phone if ever but if they're
a really good keyboard that made it easy
I would definitely like that because I'm
sure there's some keys that you could
just do without because you don't use it
that often and you could replace it with
brackets something that you use for
anyway or maybe an app that's like an
editor a mobile editor so not only does
it have the keyboard but it also has all
the features that you would have been
like a code editor the autocomplete and
things like that
anyway if anybody wants to work on that
project if you open it up and make a
repo on github all I'll try to
contribute to it
okay Noam says thanks for the suggestion
not thanking me this was earlier
thanking Rohan for the suggestion of
Rowan actually suggesting Python as well
this is actually most people using
Python tend to machine learning or data
science my favorite is creating apps
actually so nam if you're interested in
creating apps you could try to go with
one of like the native app languages so
for iOS I think it's it's Swift right
and then for Android it's Java but now
you can use Kotlin which I don't know
anything about Kotlin but I'm pretty
sure you can use it to make apps on
Android so if you wanted something else
to make apps with you could make apps
with JavaScript using react native so I
guess it depends on which what you want
to do the good thing about doing it with
JavaScript is that it would let you more
easily make apps for iOS and Android if
you just focus on on one or the other
then it would probably be a little bit
harder to switch that's my assumption I
don't really know cuz I haven't done it
but anyway that would be my advice
either JavaScript with react native or
one of the native languages for iOS or
Android
well I didn't see this so I I definitely
didn't see this so sorry if you're doing
here but it's free code camp said how
much longer you'll be streaming so I'm
assuming that was someone else logged in
as free code camp while I'm streaming he
said that I didn't even know you you
could do that but if you're still
watching I want to wrap this up by 4
o'clock
all right so I'm gonna skip through it
looks like there's a lot of discussion
about helping Blake with his I guess
there's portfolio project so I'm gonna
skip through a bunch of that how I bill
said drinking some G fuel thanks Jesse
for bringing this into my life cool I'm
glad she liked the G fuel so ahead I had
mentioned before that I I drink e fuel
and so bill had asked me about it and I
directed him to the the chief fuel site
so yeah I liked it and I guess bill
likes it so I need to get like some
affiliate programs set up so I can get I
can get you all a discount if you use my
code or something like that I think I
need a lot more people watching me
before I would they would want me to be
an affiliate
okay almost to the bottom of the live
chat
Jordan has any good videos on git and
Sarah said Udacity has some good visit
yeah actually I really like the Udacity
course on git
that was really good I I'm pretty sure
learn Codecademy that that's the YouTube
channel learn code Academy has some
videos on git
there's videos on get on for free code
camp so on this channel
yeah so between those you can get a
pretty good idea about how to use git
okay in regard to the JavaScript
debugging question from a few minutes
ago jordan says Firebug works as well
and David says Visual Studio code has
built-in JavaScript debugging that can
be used in the editor which is nice so
that's cool I didn't didn't realize that
so those are some other options John
Hanson has a question is it better to
jslint for es6 and JSX in the build or
in the atom editor it's probably you
could probably do both if you if you
want to know was better probably
probably both and then that way having
it done in the build or on commit would
enforce it for other people working on
the project but then you would have
immediate feedback of how it's supposed
to look in your browser or in your
editor if you had the editor plugin so I
would say if you're only gonna do one I
think doing it on on commit or on build
is the best if you can only have one but
if you can have both and that would be
better
services that Firefox development
browser is pretty good
now it looks like David gave Jordan
pretty much the same answer in terms of
both that are better to have in terms of
linting es6 and Rohan said it as well so
I sit a read down farther
I'm good John said thanks for the answer
you're welcome
I have Sebastian asked if I fixed the
issue with the theme no that definitely
didn't fix it so there's a there is a
branch now on github that has the mess
that I made on it so if anybody really
wants to check it out you can but
otherwise I think I'm just gonna leave
it alone for now and just continue
developing with what we had before that
actually works on the master branch so
all right well I've gotten through
everything in the live chat if I miss
your question just send it to me on
Twitter put it in the comments below
thanks so much everyone for all the help
really sorry I didn't we didn't actually
accomplish anything so it's a lot better
I think when we get something
accomplished because like we can feel
good about that but we did work through
a lot of stuff even though it didn't end
you know finally and you know us solving
the big issues but anyway it was cool we
got to dig into a lot of a lot a lot of
the node modules and you know a lot of
the code base for material UI the beta
version so that was kind of cool to see
how it all work so maybe it was useful a
bit and got to do some stuff with get
that I'd never done before so not bad
and it was good hanging out with all of
you and talking with all the years so I
will be back tomorrow should be at the
normal time 2 p.m. Eastern time and have
a great day I'll see y'all tomorrow